how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to Marvel and of course the MCU
and today we have some awesome black
widow news and this is official news as
it comes from the latest issue of Empire
magazine there are some really good
reveals in here and even a tie back to
the very first Avengers film so this
movie isn't just going to take place
between the events of Captain America's
Civil War and the events of Avengers
endgame this film is going to cover a
lot of black widows past and not to
mention the addition of a new actor and
character and the really cool news about
this new information that we got from
Empire magazine is that it really
coincides perfectly with a recent plot
leaked that we have for Black Widow so
I'll talk about this new info and the
plot leaked in this video also super
excited to announce that I have
partnered with tops to bring you Marvel
collect by tops it's a super awesome
Marvel card collection game that is on
your phone we all know everything is
digital right now so for those of you
who love collecting cards this is a
perfect app for you you can collect
cards by earning points to purchase them
with and you can trade with other people
online as well when you log in you can
spin the wheel that gives you either
cards or coins to purchase cards with
and they have some awesome packs to
choose from like the guardians of the
galaxy pack that I personally love and
they also do packs for movies that are
coming out right now you can go on and
collect the exclusive Black Widow
collection you can follow me on Marvel
collects bye tops under the username
cosmic wonder find me and let's do some
trading so right away Empire Magazine
reveals that right after the events of
Civil War Natasha is on the run and
she's being hunted down by secretary
Thunderbolt Ross now we pretty much knew
this was coming we saw him in the
trailer after all but there's most
likely more to this than just her being
on the run as a fugitive
after the sokovia accords based off of
what we've heard about the movie he is
most likely looking for her to fold one
of course is the fact that he's pretty
ticked off she was originally on his
side and Tony Stark side of the sokovia
chords but then she let Captain America
and Bucky get away there for aiding and
abetting and becoming a fugitive to
essentially the world but he's also most
likely after the Super Soldier Serum
that the black widows are being given in
the red
and he thinks that natasha has her hands
on some of it so that's most likely why
he's trying to hunt her down those two
reasons the magazine goes on to reveal
that Red Guardian is described as the
slightly budget soviet version of
captain america now we know that Red
Guardian has a form of the Super Soldier
Serum but it is not the true form that
Captain America received we know that
there were a lot of other attempts to
recreate the serum in fact a thunderbolt
ross himself has experimented on
creating the serum and so of the soviets
and it seems like they found one but it
wasn't as good as the american version
that was given to steve rogers
therefore this reveals that Red Guardian
will have some super soldier abilities
but not quite like Captain America it
then goes on to say that taskmaster is
described as every woman's nightmare
come to haunt her now this basically
confirms that taskmaster is Mason and
the former lover of Natasha now
according to a plot league for the Black
Widow film that we have it says that
Mason was a SHIELD agent
so before shield went down because it
was secretly being operated by Hydra
Mason worked for shield according to
this leak but he could have been part of
Hydra before and since he's most likely
taskmaster that would make a lot of
sense but here's the really big part it
has been revealed that Ray Winstone is
going to be in the Black Widow movie and
he's going to be playing Drake off' who
was the leader of the Red Room now this
is extremely important because this is
actually a callback to the very first
Avengers film where Loki is talking to
Natasha and when Natasha is saying that
she has red in her ledger and she needs
to clear it Loki says but can you clear
all of that red and then he starts
listing events that she has done and the
first thing that he says is Drake auvs
daughter can he wipe out that much red
during Hoffs daughter now I'm about to
talk about a pretty big spoiler so if
you don't want anything spoiled for the
movie here's your chance to click away
based off of what we know about the
Black Widow movie Drake oov wants
natasha because she killed his daughter
that's why he hires taskmaster to go and
get her he wants her to pay for killing
his daughter all those years ago so
Drake Hoff is in charge of the Red Room
now and he has all of the black widows
in the Red Room under his control he
uses and gives the black widows this
super serum and in turn it controls them
so he has control of the entire army of
black widows and this is why Natasha
wants to go and stop him so this is the
big driving force of the movie because
remember it's the Black Widow solo film
we're going to learn a lot about her a
lot has been mentioned in the MCU like
in the first Avengers when she talked
with Loki about her life so we finally
know what Drake Hobbs daughter meant
when Loki said it to Natasha and the
Avengers and she's now going to have to
confront him and also defeat him and
taskmaster too or release the black
widows from the Red Room program let me
know what you think about these reveals
and let me know what you think about
them bringing Drake often to be the
villain of this film comment down below
and don't forget to like this video and
subscribe when notifications turned on
to stay up to date on all things
relating to the MCU and so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or ps4
I'm picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
[Music]